[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم اهلا بكم في حصائد الليله
معكم محمد كريشان عواصم ومدن في العالم
تعيش الان على وقع احداث هامه البدايه من
العاصمه النيجيريه ابوجا حيث اجتمع قاده
اركان لدول المجموعه الاقتصاديه بدول غرب
افريقيا المعروفه اختيار باكواس واعلن بعد
هذا الاجتماع عن خطه لتدخل عسكري محتمل في
النيجر
الان الى اوديسا بعد هجمات اوكرانيه على
قاعده بحريه روسيه في البحر الاسود موسكو
تقول انها احبطتها وكيف تؤكد انها تسببت
في اضرار كبيره
والى العاصمه اللبنانيه بيروت ومسيرات
لاهالي ضحايا انفجار مرفا بيروت في الذكرى
الثالثه لهذا الحادث الاليم دون توصل من
السلطات السلطات التحقيق الى اي نتائج
بشانها
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
قادت اركان دول اكواس يعتمدون خطه لتدخل
عسكري محتمل في النيجر
زعماء الانقلاب يحذرون من اي تحرك عسكري
ويعلقون اتفاقات عسكريه مع فرنسا
الخارجيه الفرنسيه تقول للجزيره ان الوضع
لم يبلغ بعد مرحله التدخل والرئيس المحتجز
يطلب دعم الغرب للتصدي لتزايد النفوس
الروسي
اوكرانيا تعلن استهداف سفينه حربيه روسيه
في البحر الاسود
يشيد باداء جهاز المخابرات الاوكراني في
نقل الحرب الى الداخل الروسي موسكو تؤكد
ان سفنا روسيه دمرت زورقين مسيرين
اوكرانيين حاول مهاجمه قاعده بحريه روسيه
وتعلن اسقاط 13 طائره مسيره فوق شبه جزيره
القرم
وصل تصاعد المعارك في دارفور
بيان امريكي بريطاني النرويجي يطالب
الاطراف بوقف القتال في الاقليم والامم
المتحده تحذر من تداعياته على المدنيين
الجيش السوداني ينفي صحه ما اعلنه الدعم
السريع من السيطره على ولايه وسط دارفور
ويقصف اهدافا للدعم في منطقه بحر شمالي
الخرطوم
في لقاء اليومي قبل الحصائد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا معكم كشف مسؤولين امريكيين
عن دراسه واشنطن خطه تنشر بموجبها جنودا
على متن سفن تجاريه اثناء مرورها عبر مضيق
هرمز لاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع
كنا قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي الذي
يقول مات داعيات خطه واشنطن لنشر قوات على
متن ناقلات لردع الايران عن مصادرتها
الاجابات جاءت على النحو التالي
18% قالوا انها ستكون مواجهه بين قوات
امريكيه وايرانيه في حين قال 33% ان
التداعيات هي ضمان امن حركه الملاحه عبر
الخليج بينما فضل تسعه واربعون بالمئه
التصويت لخيار زياده منسوب التوتر الامني
في منطقه الخليج
هذا السؤال سيبقى كالعاده مطروحا على
منصتنا الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت
عبر مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر حاليا على
الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
يتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله عربيه
ودوليا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا في تونس الرئيس
السعيد يستدعي مديره التلفزيون ويواجه
انتقادات حاده للخط التحريري ونقابه
الصحفيين تستنكر ما تصف بالتدخل السافر
وتتهمه بالرغبه في توظيف الاعلام وتوجيهه
[موسيقى]
قلم مفوض مجموعه اكواس الناقده اركان
المجموعه وضعوا خطه لتدخل عسكري محتمل في
النيجر يشمل كيفيه وتوقيت نشر القوات
واضاف المفوض ان المجموعه عازمه على
معالجه الازمه في النيجر لانها ان لم تفعل
فلا احد يعرف متى
ستنتهي الانقلابات في القاره السمراء
هناك تصميم صارم من قبل رؤساء دولنا
وحكوماتنا على وضع حد للانقلابات وجعل
النيجر مثالا على ذلك للتاكد من اننا لن
نسمح مره اخرى بتعطيل تحرك المنطقه نحو
ترسيخ الديمقراطيه لن تخبر المجموعه
الاقتصاديه لدول غرب افريقيا مدبري
لانقلاب متى واين ستضرب هذا قرار عملي
يتخذه رؤساء الدول الذين سيكونون مثل
القاده العامين لهذه العمليه
لقد قلت المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه الفرنسيه
انكلاب الى انقلاب في النيجر هو من تدبير
مجموعه صغيره من العسكريين في البلاد
الذين اخذوا الرئيس المنتخب الديمقراطي
رهينه وافرضون سلطه استبداديه حسب تعبيرها
واضافت في مقابله مع الجزيره ان موقف
بلادها قريب جدا من موقف مجموعه دول غرب
افريقيا الداعي لاستعاده السلطه الدستوريه
في النيجر
هؤلاء مجموعه معزوله ولا يحظون بدعم
المجتمع الدولي او الاتحاد الافريقي دول
غرب افريقيا اتخذت موقفا شديدا ضد
الانقلابيين وموقفنا قريب من ايكوس ونحاول
العوده للوضع الدستوري وان نضع كل وزننا
في المفاوضات والوسط
واكدت المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه الفرنسيه
كذلك ان الهدف في هذا الوقت هو تجنب
الوصول الى فرضيه التدخل العسكري في
النيجر على الرغم من وجود خطه وضعها رؤساء
اركان دول مجموعه غرب افريقيا
ان يسمعوا رساله المجتمع الدولي اي تحرير
الرئيس والعوده للنظام الدستوري
الانقلابيون يسيرون في طريق مسدود سياسيا
وامنيا لان عقوبات اكواس قويه جدا
وتاثيراتها كبيره قطعت الكهرباء عن النيجر
وتوقفت المعاملات التجاريه وهناك انذار
باحتمال استخدام القوه ولا بد من اخذ هذه
الانذارات بطريقه جديه وزياده الضغط على
الانقلابيين
وينضم الينا من عاصمه الدكتور علي يعقوب
الاكاديمي والمحلل السياسي اهلا وسهلا بك
دكتور بعد وضع الخطه هل تراها يمكن ان
تطبق قريبا خطه التدخل العسكري طبعا
شكرا على كل حال
لا ندري متى
تبقى هل ستكون قريبه او
بعيدا لا نجد على كل حال
ستكون سهله او بدون اراقه الدماء
لا تكون بسهولها اما وان ياتي بالسيارات
فهذه المشكله الاخرى وبالطائرات سيدمرون
قصر الجمهور الذي يكسر الرئاسه الذي يقع
في الوسط الازمه وفي احياء السكنيه فلا
ادري لاعادتي الى الديمقراطيه او تحريف
واحد ندمر لكل العاصمه او كيف الله اعلم
على كل حال ننتظر الايام ماذا
ستفرح
في انتظار ذلك نعم في انتظار ذلك هل تعتقد
بان العسكريين سيراجعون حساباتهم بعد ان
وضعت هذه الخطه عمليا
لا اعتقد على العسكريون ليس لهم تفكير في
تراجع هذا غير وارد اصلا في خطته لانه
وصلوا الى نقطه الى عوده
دائما يعينون وينظمون الامور البلاد من
حيث
الحكام وكذا وكذا الى اخر شيء لا عوده
الان نفقد نسال الله السلامه
وياتينا بالفرج من حيث
هل هناك احساس في في انيامي هناك بان هذه
الضربه العسكريه قد تكون قريبه
كلام كثير الباب يرون انها قريبه منك يوم
الاحد والباري يرون انهم مستحيل لا يمكن
والبادي يرون انها بعيده الناس مختلفون في
تحليلاتهم لهذه الدربه العسكريه اشرت الى
ان العسكريين وصلوا الى نقطه لا عوده
برايك لماذا لم يسعوا لمقابله الوفد الذي
جاء ليفاوضهم على الاقل يستطيعون ان
يعرفوا الى اين تتجه الامور
المفاوضه شجره اذا كان هناك عملية ممكن
نقف عليها
هم يعرفون هم قابلوهم في المطار
خمس ساعات ما هي المفاوضه المفاوض هو انتم
اذهبوا ويرجع الى الحديد الرئيس المعزوم
ما يمكن تفاعله على هذا الاساس وكيف حتى
لم
لم يدخلوا في العاشمه من هناك رجل وكيف
يمكن ان ينظر الى الموقف الفرنسي لانه رغم
كل ما جرى فرنسا لا تبدو متحمسه كثيرا
لتدخل عسكري
الله
فرنساها ولا نستبد حتى لها فيما يحدث والا
ما علاقتها بكل هذه الاشياء
وتدخل في دوله
مستقله كما تبدا انسحها
قامت بشيء داخلي
والمفروض تمدد وتسكت ولكن بالعكس دائما
تقول هي مع سيدي او ما يسمى
من الذين من الدول التي تدبر هذه التربه
العسكريه لاجل المسامير لكن اعتقد سواء
ضرب نيجر او لم يضرب لن تبقى فرنسا بشكل
مريهم كما كانت ان خلال ثقه الناس بها
انتهت
من عاصمه النيجر نيامي الدكتور علي يعقوب
الاكاديميه والمحله السياسي شكرا جزيلا
لكم
[موسيقى]
قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه انها افشلته
هجوما بزوارق مسيره على ميناء
في وقت نفذت او نقلت فيه وكاله رويترز عن
مصدر امنيين اوكرانيا القول ان الهجوم نجح
في الحق اضرار بسفينه انزال روسيه بينما
اكتفى الرئيس الاوكراني بتوجيه الشكر
لجهاز امن الدوله لنقله المعركه الى روسيا
حسب تعبيرها التفاصيل في هذا التقرير
البحر الاسود والسيناريو الصراع عليه وفيه
قد يكون بابا مفتوحا على احتمالات كثيره
الخطوط الحمراء لم تعد مقتصره على الشواطئ
الاوكرانيه
توسعت دائره الخطر فما الذي يجري في البحر
الاسود صباح الجمعه تعلن وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه ان القوات الاوكرانيه حاولت
مهاجمه ميناء نوفروسيسك في البحر الاسود
باستخدام زورقين مسيرين وتضيف الوزاره ان
السفن الروسيه التي تعمل على حراسه
الميناء دمرت الزورقين يلي ذلك تصريح
نقلته وكاله رايترز ونسبته لمصدر امني
اوكراني مفاده ان جهاز الامن الاوكراني
نفذ بالاشتراك مع القوات البحريه
الاوكرانيه عمليه في خليج نيوروسيسك
الروسي وبحسب المصدر نفذت العمليه بزورق
مسير يحمل نحو نصف طن من المتفجرات استهدف
سفينه انزال روسيه في وقت اكتفى المتحدث
باسم المخابرات الاوكرانيه بتاكيد الهجوم
دون تبنيه
في موسكو هناك اجسام طائره مجهوله الهويه
وهنا الان توجد مسيرات مجهوله الهويه
الحقت اضرارا بسفينه الانزال هذه على
المستوى الامني هذه خساره كبيره لاسطول
المحتلين بخسارتهم سفينه كبيره
اما الرئيس الاوكراني فعبر عن امتنانه
لجهاز امن الدوله
قدم لي رئيس اداره امن الدوله تقريرا لن
اتحدث عن محتواه ساقول فقط اننا جميعا
ممتنون لجهاز امن الدوله الاوكراني
لاعادته الحرب الى الدوله المعتديه
[موسيقى]
ونقلت محطه سي ان ان الامريكيه عن مصدر
اوكراني قوله ان 100 جندي روسي كانوا على
متن السفينه التي اصيبت باضرار وخرجت عن
الخدمه الهجوم بذاته بصرف النظر عن دقه
الروايتين له دلالات كبيره الميناء
المستهدف هو اكبر ميناء في البلاد يحتوي
على اطول خط رسو يتجاوز طوله ثمانيه كيلو
مترات ويحتل موقعا استراتيجيا باعتباره
مفترق طرق النقل الدوليه بين روسيا والبحر
الابيض المتوسط ومناطق في اسيا والسفينه
المنخرطه في الحدث هي اولينيغورسكي
غورنياك دخلت الخدمه عام 67
واعتبرت افضل سفن الانزال في الاسطول
الشمالي الروسي خضعت لعمليات اصلاح وتحديث
انتهت عام 2019
وعدت للخدمه بدايه العام الماضي
المستشار في وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه
ورئيس المركز الاوكراني للامن والتعاون
ومن موسكو فزيل
ضابط الاحتياط في الجيش الروسي اهلا بهما
نبدا من كيف وسيد كوزان هل ما جرى يشيء
بان المرحله المقبله ستكون مرحله
المواجهات البحريه الكبرى
ان هذه المرحله تبدا الان
والدولتين هم دولتين لديهما اسطلين بحريين
حتى وان لم يكن لدى اوكرانيا
اسطولا خاصا بها ولكنها لديها مجموعه من
المسيرات المائيه التي تدمر الاسطول
الروسي وكل السفن العسكريه او ربما كل
البنيه التحتيه التي سوف تستخدم في التي
استخدمت عفوا في احتلال القرن وفي العدوان
الغير قانوني من قبل روسيا وهذا سوف يدمر
ولن يبقى هناك اي من المعتدين في البحر
ولكن هل هل اوكرانيا لدى لديها القدره على
الوقوف الندله الند مع روسيا في المجال
البحري
بالطبع اليوم
حتى نقوم بمعارك نوعيه نحتاج لسفن
وليس لدينا قدرات ان نحافظ على سفن كبيره
في البحر الاسود لذلك نهتم
بالمسيرات المائيه
والتي تطفو فوق الماء وتحته
او الصواريخ من انواع كربون او نبتون لهذا
السيد في موسكو هل هذا النوع من الاسلحه
الاوكرانيه التي يشير اليها ضيفنا الحقت
فعلا الضرر بروسيا على الاقل كما يبدو
بشكل جلي الان اليوم
النظر عن
اعلن عن حوالي 400 كيلو جرام من المفجرات
الغربيه هذا هي المسيره التي اصاف اصابت
السفينه
ولكنها لم تؤدي الى اضرار فادحه انا
كمهندس انا كمهندس
عماره سفن اريد ان اقول ان اغراق مثل هذه
السفينه شيء صعب صعب جدا قد يحتاج لاغراق
مثل هذه السفن تفجير ضخم جدا لان النقطتين
التي تم اجراء فيهما خرق في جسم
السفينه هذا لم يؤدي الى تصرف مياه كبير
واريد ان اقول ان السفينه التي تضررت لم
تكن تقوم بمهام عسكريه
تحمي الحدود في تلك المنطقه والان نحن
نقوم باعمال احتياطيه وننقل البضائع
بكميات محدوده والسفن العسكريه تدافع عن
هذه السفن وهذه السفينه كانت تحمل مواد
مدنيه ولكن بغض النظر عن هذه التفاصيل
مجرد اصابه سفينه الا يعتبر
ضرب لصوره ومكانه روسيا البحريه في تلك
المنطقه
انها اعمال عسكريه كما تعلم جاريه الان
وهذه ليست الضربه الاولى التي نجحت جزئيا
ضد سفننا للاسف ولكن كان هناك الكثير من
المحاولات لضرب
سفننا وتحدثنا عن هذا كثيرا امامكم في
البث
والكثير من السفن التي تحمي المنطقه وتحمي
ايضا انابيب نقل الطاقه هجمت من هذه
المسيرات مسبقا وتم تدميرها تماما ونفس
هذه الاشكال من المثيرات انها حرب كما
تعلم وللاسف هناك ضربات تمر ليس هناك اي
ضحايا كما اريد ان اؤكد والادار على
السفينه قليله جدا وسوف تعود هذه السفينه
للعمل قريبا الى جانب هذه المواجهه
البحريه سيد كوزان في في كييف حديث
اوكرانيا عن نقل المعركه الى الداخل
الروسي هل هو نهج سيتواصل ويشتد في الفتره
المقبله
هذا شيء صحيح على الاراضي الروسيه هناك
مراكز وقواعد عسكريه
وعدا عن بحر الاذوف حيث
تستخدم هذه المناطق من قبل الروس كقواعد
عسكريه وللسفن الحربيه وبما فيها هذه
السفينه التي اريد ان اؤكد انها سفينه
سفينه انزال عسكريه تستخدم لنقل الجنود
ولذلك هذا كان هدفا شرعيا
وكاي بنيه تحتيه عسكريه في نظر سيسك ولان
هذا الميناء هو الذي يؤمن المناطق المحتله
ولذلك كل الوسائل التي ممكن ان توقف وان
تحارب ضد الاحتلال الروسي سوف تكون اهداف
شرعيه من مع ضيفنا من موسكو السيد
ذهاب موسكو الى فرد التجنيد الاجباري على
كل من اعمارهم تتراوح بين 18 والثلاثين
كيف يمكن ان يقرا ذلك
[موسيقى]
هذا ليس تفسيرا سليما ليس لكل شخص لدينا
نظاما للخدمه العسكريه حيث يكون هناك
ضروره ولدينا نظاما يسمح لنا ان
يقوم الشخص بخدمه العلم بعد انهائه من
التعليم العالي
ولذلك الان كان لدينا نظام يسمح للخدمه
العلم بعد حتى سن 27 والان رفعناه الى
ثلاثين وهذا شيء طبيعي لان الشباب وعددهم
اصبح اكبر على اساس القانون كان يعرف
الشاب على انه حتى عمر 27 والان حتى
الثلاثين وتسمح لي بالعوده على اضرابات ضد
السفن اعتقد انه اذا استمرت هذه الهجمات
كما قال الضيف من كيف عندها قد نحن
للاستخدام وسائل اكثر جديه نحن لن نستخدم
جميع انواع الصواريخ والقنابل التي لدينا
ولكنهم يجبروننا على هذا واوكرانيا هي من
تزيد حده وسخونه المعارك ولا ادري لماذا
يريدون هذا شكرا جزيلا سيد بازيلي من
موسكو شكرا لضيفنا ملكيه سيره كوزان
السعوديه ان المملكه ستستضيف يوم غد
اجتماعا لممثلي عدد من الدول بشان الازمه
الاوكرانيه واشارت الى ان الحكومه
السعوديه تتطلع ان يسهم الاجتماع في تعزيز
الحوار والتعاون على المستوى الدولي بشان
حل الازمه الاوكرانيه وبما يجنب العالم
مزيدا من التداعيات الانسانيه والامنيه
والاقتصاديه ياتي ذلك في وقت نقلت فيه
وكاله عن مصدر بوزاره الخارجيه الروسيه ان
السعوديه ابلغت روسيا بانها ستطلعها على
نتائج هذا الاجتماع وقالت الصين انها
ستنفد مسؤولا بارزا الى المملكه العربيه
السعوديه لحضور اجتماع جده الرامي لايجاد
تسويه سلميه للحرب في اوكرانيا من جهته
قال الرئيس الاوكراني فلو ميرسي لانسكي ان
اجتماع جده سيكون هاما للغايه لان مصير
الملايين في افريقيا واسيا ومناطق اخرى من
العالم يتوقف مباشره على مدى سرعه تحقيق
صيغه للسلام حسب تعبيره
[موسيقى]
قالت الخارجيه الامريكيه ان مجموعه
الترويكا وهي النرويج وبريطانيا والولايات
المتحده تدين العنف المستمر في دارفور
بالسودان وخصوصا ما جاء في تقارير عن
عمليات القتل على اساس العرق والعنف
الجنسي الواسع النطاق من قبل قوات الدعم
السريع والمليشيات المتحالفه معها واضافت
الخارجيه ان الدول الثلاث تدعو جميع
الاطراف الى الوقف الفوري لهذه الهجمات في
دارفور ومحاسبه المسؤولين عنها والسماح
بالوصول الى المناطق المتضرره حتى يمكن
التحقيق في الانتهاكات اضافه الى وصول
المساعدات الانسانيه واشارت الترويكا الى
ان توسع الصراع المدمر الذي لا داعي له
الى دارفور تسبب في معاناه انسانيه لا
تحصى
وكانت البعثه الامميه في السودان قد عبرت
عن قلقها البالغ ازاء التاثيرات الخطيره
للقتال بين قوات الدعم السريع والجيش
السوداني على المدنيين في ولايه دارفور
واستنكرت البعثه في بيان لها التقارير
التي تشير الى منع المدنيين من المغادره
نحو المناطق الامنه الامر الذي ادى الى
وقوع ضحايا وفق البيان واتهمت البعثه في
بيانها قوات الدعم السريع والمليشيات
المتحركه معها بالاستهداف العشوائي للسكان
المدنيين والمرافق العامه بغربي ولايه
دارفور
مشهد يومي مالوف في سماء العاصمه
السودانيه تحلق الطائرات فوق مدن العاصمه
الثلاث وقال مراسل الجزيره ان الطيران قصف
اهدافا للدعم السريع في مدينه الخرطوم
بحري وحسب مصادر عسكريه تحدثت للجزيره فان
الجيش هاجم ارتكازات الدعم السريع بمنطقه
حله كوكو واحدث خسائر في المعدات والارواح
لا يختلف الحال كثيرا في المناطق الملتهبه
الاخرى خاصه في دارفور اعلن قائد الدعم
السريع في وسط دارفور السيطره الكامله على
الولايه وهو ما نفاه الجيش بشده ظلت
المعارك وعمليات الكر والفر تدور في
الاقليم سيالا منذ اندلاع الحرب في منتصف
ابريل الماضي وتنتقل من ولايه لاخرى في
ولايات الاقليم الخمس وخلال هذه المعارك
دمر القصف مدينه الجنينه عاصمه غرب دارفور
ونزح معظم سكانها لدوله كاد المجاوره
وكان الجيش بث صورا قال انها الانضمام
عسكريا من ميليشيا حرس الحدود التابعه
للدعم السريع بكامل عتادهم الى الجيش في
مدينه نيالا عاصمه ولايه جنوب دارفور
منظمه الاغذيه وزراعه التابعه للامم
المتحده فاو دقت ناقوس الخطر محذره من شبح
مجاعه طاحنه توشك على احكام قبضتها في
السودان قالت المنظمه الدوليه ان سته
ملايين شخص في البلاد اصبحوا الان على
حافه المجاعه فعلا وتتفاقم الازمه يوما
بعد اخر وهم جزء من نحو 20 مليون اي ما
يعادل 42% من السكان يعانون من انعدام
الامن الغذائي بشكل حاد
ورغم ازدياد عدد النازحين واللاجئين بسبب
حرب الجيش وقوات الدعم السريعه فان
الثابته براي كثيرين هو عدم تحرك الامم
المتحده كما يجب لوقف الحرب وافرازاتها
الخطيره في مختلف الاتجاهات
ومع اعتراف بعثه الامم المتحده في السودان
بحدوث جرائم وتجاوزات لحقوق الانسان خلال
هذه الحرب فانها تكتفي حتى الان بدعوه
الطرفين للالتزام بالقانون الدولي
الانساني وحمايه المدنيين وضمان سلامتهم
وهو ما ينعدم تماما في ارض المعارك
ومعنا في الاستوديو ضياء الدين بلال
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي السوداني اهلا
وسهلا بك برايك لماذا بدت المواقف الدوليه
على الاقل النرويج وبريطانيا وليله
المتحده اكثر صرامه وقوه في الحديث عما
يجري في دارفور نعم ربما ذلك الاستصحاب ما
كان يحدث في السابق والجرائم التي ارتكبت
في عام 2003 فهي تعيد ما يحدث الان يعيد
الذاكره لتلك الاحداث والتي وصلت الى
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه واخرجت كثير من
التقارير الدوليه حولها كما ان التجاوزات
التي تتم من قبل الدعم السريع في هذه
المناطق تعتبر تجاوزات بكل المقاييس
تجاوزات كبيره
ومؤثره وتصل الى درجه الاباده الجماعيه
والتطهير الارقي وهذه من الجرائم التي
تستثير الحساسيه المجتمع الدولي والمنظمات
الدوليه والدول بشكل عام هذه الدول دعت
الى التحقيق فيما يجري هل من السهل القيام
بذلك في اجواء السودان الحاليه من الان
التحقيق واعتقد ان الدور المجتمعه الدولي
في ايقاف ما يحدث في السودان اعتقد انه
ضعيف الى حد كبير جدا
والسودان وحاصه دارفور يقع في منطقه
بها كثير من الالتهابات العسكريه
والحدوديه الان تلاحظ ما يحدث في تشاد وما
يحدث في النيجر والسودان له صله قويه بما
يحدث في هذه المناطق لانه هنالك تداخل
كبير ما بين القبائل وما بين الاجنده
السياسيه العابره للحدود اذا كان في
النيجر واذا كان في التشاد واذا كان في
افريقيا الوسطى كما ان للدعم السريع مناجم
ذهب وثروه طائله في هذه المنطقه لذلك هو
يركز على هذه المنطقه خاصه في وسط دارفور
الدعم السريع يركز على هذه المناطق تركيدا
كبيرا لان كما قلت قبل قليل بها كثير من
المناجم وهنالك وجود له فاغنر في هذه على
تماس هذه المنطقه
فهذه المنطقه شديده الالتهاب فبالتالي
انظار المجتمع الدولي وتكتزب انظار
المنظمات الدوليه
لما يجري في هذه المنطقه من تجاوزات كبيره
ولكن اصلا كيف يمكن ان نفهم ان المعارك
التي كانت مركزه بالاساس في العاصمه تنتقل
بين فتره واخرى الى دارفور بين الجيش
وواتوات الدعم هل من تفسير لذلك نعم يبدو
التفسير الواضح ان الدعم السريع لم يعد
قادره على ان يشن هجوم بذاته الطريق
القديمه والكثافه الناريه التي كان يشم
بها الهجوم على المناطق العسكريه واكبر
هجوم تم شنه من قبل الدعم السريع في يوم
25 يونيو ما يقارب شهر وزياده ولم تعد
قوته العسكريه مؤثره في هذه المناطق وواضح
ان الجيش استطاع بقدر كبير جدا ان يفتت
القوه المركزيه للدعم السريع فاصبحت
فاصبحت دعم السريع في العاصمه الخرطوم لا
يملك زمام المبادره كما كان يفعل من قبل
بل هو تحول الى مرحله دفاعيه وتحول الجيش
الى مرحله هجوميه للقضاء
وحصر انشطه العسكريه للدعم السريع في
العاصمه الدول الثلاث تتحدث عن اعتداءات
وقتل على اساس العرق والعنف الجنسي الواسع
وتتهم قوات الدعم السريع والميليشيات
المتحالفه معه من هي هذه الميليشيات هذه
يبدو انها محاوله محاوله لتبرئه الدعم
السريع من كامل المسؤوليه الدعم السريع
المسؤول عن كل هذه الميليشيات لان الدعم
السريع حينما يقوم بالاستقطاع في هذه
المنطقه يقوم على اساس الاستقطاب ليس
استقطاب فرديا ولكن استقطاب مجموعات وهذه
المجموعات تكون تحت قياده عسكريه وهذه
القياده العسكريه هي قياده الدعم السريع
فبالتالي اي محاوله للفصل ما بين الدعم
والميليشيات اعتقد انها محاوله
للتبرئه الدعم السريع من كثير من الجرائم
التي يرتكبها ويقتربها في هذه المنطقه
شكرا جزيلا لك ضياء الدين بلال على حضورك
معنا هنا
[موسيقى]
الى لبنان حيث تحل اليوم الذكرى السنويه
الثالثه الانفجار مرفا بيروت دون توصل
السلطات التحقيق الى اي نتائج بشانها
ويواجه التحقيق انقسامات سياسيه وعقبات
قضائيه جمدت عمل المحقق العدلي طارق
البيطار
ثلاث سنوات وما زال الامل يحدو الحاجه ندى
بعوده
ابنها في ذاك الرابع من اب قل لذا رتبه في
الجيش ذهب بعدها الى الخدمه العسكريه في
مرفا بيروت ولم يعد
بس يمكن يمكن ايمن حبيبي والله
بترجع لي
بالغلط بلكي كان شيء طالب الحقيقه بدنا
نعرف مين كلهم بقولوا هيدا هيدا بحطها على
هيدا وهيدا بيحطها على هيدا ما عم نعرف
شيء
الاف الضحايا والمتضررين ما زالوا بانتظار
العداله عداله تبدو معطله نتيجه عقبات عده
تواجه التحقيق وليس القضاء بمن انعنها
هناك ثغرات في القانون الذي ينظم اصول
المحاكمات في لبنان والتي تسمح بتعليق
التحقيق بمجرد تقديم دعاوى لرد القاضي
ولمخاصمته ومجلس النواب لم يتخذ اي اجراء
من اجل تعديل تعديل هذه القوانين لسد هذه
الثغرات كما لم تتخذ اي من السلطات الاخرى
اي اجراءات لازاله العراقيل
سكون المكان الذي لم يعد اعماره بعد
يقابله صخب الخلافات السياسيه بشان هذه
القضيه
فمنذ ادعاء المحقق العدلي طارق البيطار
على مسؤولين سياسيين انقسمت البلاد بين
فريق اتهمه بتسييس الملف واخر داعم له
وبعدما وصل الخلاف الى الشارع علقت تحقيق
في متاهه دعاون هاله على البيطار لتنحيته
ما ادى الى تجميد التحقيق منذ اكثر من عام
ونصف العام بخلافات السياسيه وايضا طبيعه
العمل السياسي في لبنان الذي يرفض اي مسار
للعداله بشكل مستقل عن الاراده السياسيه
لهذا لم نرى اي تحقيق ناجح او اي محاسبه
لاي مسؤول لبناني رغم الفشل الذريع الذي
رايناه خلال العقود الماضيه
ومع تراكم العراقيل في وجه التحقيق المحلي
تطالب منظمات حقوقيه لبنانيه ودوليه
بتحقيق اممي وباصلاحات تحيد القضاء عن
التدخلات السياسيه وتحمي استقلاليته كما
تقول يشبه البعض الفوضى القائمه في المرفا
هنا بعد ثلاثه اعوام على الانفجار بتلك
التي تعم التحقيقات المتعثره في هذه
القضيه تعثر يخشى معه اهالي الضحايا عدم
الكشف عن الحقيقه في بلد يقولون ان جرائم
كثيره ارتكبت فيه على مر العقود الماضيه
دون محاسبه مقترفها كاترين حنا الجزيره من
مرفا بيروت
هذا وقد قالت سيسيليا روكز المحاميه وعضو
لجنه اهالي ضحايا انفجار مرفا بيروت انهم
سيستمرون في تحركاتهم ووقفاتهم الاحتجاجيه
حتى يتم انصاف الضحايا واتهمت روكز في
مقابله مع الجزيره الطبقه السياسيه في
لبنان بالمسؤوليه عن عرقله التحقيقات
الخاصه بالانفجار والمماطله في الاجراءات
القضائيه
احنا بعدنا من اول ما طلع الانفجار ومن
اول ما تعين القضاه ومشي والدعوه على
سياسيين بلشت العرقلات السياسيه والحزبيه
كلها هدول العالم يلي متحالفين مع بعضهم
هن يلي ما بدهن التحقيق يمشوا قبل ما
يتعين القاضي سمعتك عم بتقول انه عم
يتهموه بالتسييس ما حدا مسيس هذا الملف
هيدا ملف دمر المدينه وقتل العالم مين عم
بيسايسه هن اللي عم بيسايسوا السياسيين
نحن شو عم نطلب عم نطلب العداله
هذا وينضم الينا الان من بيروت طارق عبود
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي اهلا وسهلا بك الى
متى سيستمر هذا الجرح مفتوحا دون الوصول
الى الحقيقه
بدايه كل العزاء لاهالي الشهداء في تفجير
مرفا بيروت في اربعه 2020 وتحياتي اليك
استاذ محمد الموضوع خاضع للتحقيق للسلطات
القضائيه يعني الشهداء المرفا اهالي شهداء
المرفا كل اللبنانيين ينتظرون تحقيقا
شفافا يؤدي الى غايات محدده تعرف من هو
المسؤول عن هذا الانفجار الكارثي الذي هو
من اكبر الانفجارات غير النوويه التي حصلت
في المئه سنه الماضيه لذلك اليوم يعني
اللبنانيون يطرحون اسئله عديده بغض النظر
عن تسييس وبغض النظر عن يعني اخذ الملف
الى اماكن لا تؤدي ولن تؤدي الى كشف
الحقيقه الاسئله المطروحه اليوم بعد ثلاث
سنوات المطروحه على المحقق العدلي وعلى
الجهات
وحتى على مجلس قضاء الاعلى من الذي اتى
بهذه النترات الى بيروت ومن الذي حمى ان
زالها ومن الذي يعني امر بابقائها منذ عام
2014 الى اربعه 2020 يعني هذا السؤال هذا
السؤال سيد عبود هذا السؤال تحديدا اذا
اخذنا مما قاله النائب سامي جميل يقول هذه
النترانات قدست في المرفا لحروب حزب الله
وبالتالي دائما هناك اشاره الى هذا الطرف
وهناك شعور عام بان هناك تمص لهذه المساله
تحديدا
على ما يقوله النائب سامي جميل يعني يا
معزوفه حقيقه يقولها او يعني يقودها فريق
سياسي محدد حزب الله ليس بحاجه الى نترات
حتى يضعها في مرفا بيروت وكل الكون كان
يعرف ان هناك
2750 طن من النيترات في مرفق بيروت يعني
حزب الله ليس بحاجه الى هذه الكميه وليس
بحاجه الى ان يخزنها في المرفا وهناك ايضا
يعني القوات البحريه لليونيف القوات
الالمانيه هي التي سمحت بانزال النترات في
مرفا بيروت هذا كلام سياسي يراد منه اهداف
سياسيه اذا كنا نريد الحقيقه فعليا في
مرفا في انفجار مرفا بيروت علينا ان نجيب
عن هذه الاسئله طيب اين الصور الجويه قبل
واثناء وبعد الانفجار السؤال مطروح
واشكالي ومهم ومفصلي وكيف الحقيقه
يعني هناك مفارقه الحقيقه عندما تطلع على
تصريحات اليوم في هذه الذكرة سواء من حسن
نصر الله سامي جميل كل القيادات السياسيه
الكل يتحدث عن كشف الحقيقه
في النهايه من الذي يخفي هذه الحقيقه اذا
كان الكل يريد الحقيقه
[موسيقى]
في لبنان لم يالوا جهدا لكي يستثمروا في
هذا الانفجار الكبير لتحقيق اهداف سياسيه
للتصويب على المقاومه في لبنان وهذا
السياق معروف يعني لا نكشف سرا اليوم
السياق الذي يعني كان منذ العام 2019 منذ
الثوره او ثوره 17 20 في لبنان كان سياقه
واضح واجر الانفجار يعني تحقيق هذه
الاهداف والا يعني اذا لم يكن التحقيق
جديا لن نصل الى نتيجه في من فجر المرفا
في بيروت في اربعه عام 2020 طارق عبود من
بيروت شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
انتقد الرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد اداء
التلفزيون العموميه التونسيه وقال خلال
لقائه المدير العامه لهذا التلفزيون عواطف
التالي ان ما يبث في التلفزيون الوطني يجب
ان يكون في خدمه التونسيين وليس في خدمه
اللوبيات حسب تعبير
ما يتم بثو بهذه الطريقه
من قبل مؤسسه وطنيه
لا يمكن ان يستمر يجب ان تكون المؤسسه
الوطنيه في خدمه
التونسيين والتون
لا في خدمه هذه اللوبيا التي تتخفى وراء
الستار
لقد استنكرت نقابه الصحفيين التونسيين ما
وصفته بالتدخل المباشر لرئيس الجمهوريه
قيس سعيد في الاعلام العمومي والتلفزيون
التونسي وقالت النقابه في بيان ان
التدخلات سعيد وصلت حتى التدخل في ترتيب
فقرات النشرات الاخباريه والمضامين
الاعلاميه بل والضيوف في البرامج واضافت
النقابه ان التدخل هذا يندرج في سياق كامل
من الرقابه على الاعلام لتوظيفه وتوجيهه
في اتجاه واحد وفق ما جاء في البيان
قال الرئيس جبهه الوطني في تونس احمد نجيب
الشابي ان البلاد في اشد الحاجه الى حكومه
انقاذ وطني ودع الشاب في مؤتمر الصحفي الى
التوافق عبر حوار وطني حول برنامج حكومه
الانقاذ مضيفا انه لا يمكن التعويل على
قيس سعيد في اداره هذا الحوار وتشكيل
حكومه الانقاذ
خلص الوطني تؤكد ان حكومه الانقاذ الوطني
هي المطلوبه ان الحوار الوطني هو الاطار
الاوحد لابرازها وان
المعنيين بها ليس قيس سعيد قيس سعيد رفض
الحوار منذ ان اتى وقت الاتحاد الشغل هزل
المبادره بتاعه عامين ونص تقريبا قال لهم
اخطاتم العنوان انا مانيش هنا بنسمعكمش
[موسيقى]
اعلنت اثيوبيا حاله الطوارئ في اقليم امهر
المطرب منذ اسبوع الذي يشهدوا مواجهات
عنيفه بين مسلحي فانوا والقوات النظاميه
[موسيقى]
اثيوبيا في مواجهه اخطر ازمه داخليه بعد
حرب تيجراي الاخيره حلفاء الامس في تلك
الحرب يتقاتلون اليوم في امهره تصعدت
وتيره العنف بين القوات الوطنيه وميليشيا
فانو منذ اسبوع خروج الوضع عن السيطره دفع
بالسلطات الاقليم الى طلب النجده من
اديسببا انتاج اجتماع مجلس الوزراء باتخاذ
جمله من القرارات لاحتواء الازمه التي
تهدد مره اخرى وحده البلاد وجاء في بيان
مكتب رئيس الوزراء ابي احمد انه من
الضروري اعلان حاله الطوارئ اذ اصبح من
الصعب السيطره على هذه الاحداث العنيفه
باتباع النظام القانوني العادي حاله
الطوارئ تمنح الحكومه سلطه حظر التجمعات
وشن حمله اعتقالات دون اوامر قضائيه وفردي
حظر التجوال لاقليم امهر خصوصيات جغرافيه
وتاريخيه فهو ثاني البلاد ويقتنه 23 مليون
نسمه وعاصمته بحردار له حدود مع اريتريا
ويحده السودان من الغرب والشمال الغربي
واقليم تيجراي الاثيوبي من الشمال هو منبع
النيل وبحيره تانا التي تمثل المنبع ايضا
للنيل الازرق والى هذا الاقليم ينتمي
اباطره اثيوبيا من الامبراطور هيلاسيلاسي
الى مينيليك وتدرس ومنغسته الى مريم
وتنحدر
الرئيسوزي من اقليم امهره فانهي ميليشيا
سندت الجيش الاثيوبي خلال عامين حرب التي
وضعت اوزارها في نوفمبر الماضي بين ان
قرار اديس ابا منتصف ابريل الماضي تفكيك
القوات الخاصه في احدى عشره منطقه اثيوبيه
اشعل فتيله صراع جديد لن يكون يسيرا
اخماده امر ابي احمد بادماج تلك القوات في
الشرطه او الجيش لم يرحب به من الجميع
بالنظر القوميين الامهريين سيضعف ذلك
الاجراء منطقتهم ترد الحكومه المركزيه بان
الهدف هو الحفاظ على الوحده الوطنيه يصعب
التاكد من مصدر مستقل بشان تفاصيل
الاشتباكات بين مسلحي فانو والقوات
الحكوميه ومن يسيطر على ماذا المؤكد ان
الامن مفقود هناك الى اجل غير مسمى علقت
الخطوط الجويه الاثيوبيه رحلاتها الى
ثلاثه مطارات من اصل اربعه في امهره وحذرت
السفاره الغربيه مواطنيها من التوجه الى
هناك نظرا لخطوره الوضع امهر هل سينجح ابي
احمد في انهاء الازمه سريعا انفتح على
نفسه باسم الوحده الوطنيه جبهه تزعزع
الاستقرار الهشه على الحدود بين هذا
الاقليم وتيجراي وربما في مناطق اخرى من
البلاد
[موسيقى]
التطورات الاخيره في النيجر والتي تابعنا
جزءا منها سلطت الضوء مجددا على منطقه غرب
افريقيا والساحل فما الذي نعرفه عن هذه
المنطقه تعد منطقه الساحل الافريقي من اهم
المناطق الجغرافيه والاستراتيجيه ليس في
افريقيا فقط بل في العالم اذ تستحوذ هذه
المنطقه على موقعا جغرافيا متميز تتوسط
منطقه الساحل القاره الافريقيه مع قرب
اكثر الى الشمال وتمتد من السنغال والراس
الاخضر وموريتاني غربا وصولا الى السودان
واثيوبيا وجيبوتي شرقا مرورا بمالي
والنيجر وتشات في حدود الساحل الافريقيه
من الشمال يوجد المغرب والجزائر وليبيا
وصولا الى مصر ويمتد هذا الساحل جنوبا الى
اقاسي بوركينا فاسو واجزاء من جمهوريه
افريقيا
الوسطى مع انه يتسع ويضيق في غير انتظام
اي اننا نتحدث عن منطقه تشمل تلك الدول
الممتده من المسافه على المسافه من المحيط
الاطلسي غربا الى البحر الاحمر شرقا فيقع
الساحل الافريقي في اجزاء من كل من
الجزائر والسنغال موريتانيا مالي بوركينا
فاسو النيجر نيجيريا جنوب السودان تشاد
السودان الراس الاخضر جمهوريه افريقيا
الوسطى
اثيوبيا هي مساحه صحراويه شاسعه تمتد من
الشرق الى الغرب على طول 5900 كيلو متر
ومن الجنوب الى الشمال بطول عده مئات الى
الف كيلو متر وتغطي مساحته اكثر من ثلاثه
ملايين كم مربع من الاراضي نشير الى ان
الساحل استمد اسمه من العربيه
وقد احتفظ بها في اللغات الاخرى وتعني
الشاطئ او الحد وهو ما ينطبق عليه تماما
نظرا لتوسطه مناخين وبيئتين متباينه
استعرضنا الموقع ولكن ماذا عن الاهميه
الجيو السياسيه منطقه الساحل غنيه
بالموارد الطبيعيه والحيويه نتحدث هنا عن
النفط وثروات عديده كالذهب والنفط
واليورانيوم والفوسفات هي منطقه نفوذ
جيوسياسي فرنسي منذ عقول لكن احداثا
وتحولات وحسابات عالميه جعلت منها محطات
تنافس فقبل التطورات الاخيره في نيامي
ذكرت صحيفه التايمز البريطانيه في تقرير
يعود الى اكتوبر من العام الماضي ان
النيجر ستكون الدوله التاليه التي تخسرها
فرنسا لصالح روسيا في غرب افريقيا واشنطن
ايضا ليست بعيده عن هذه المنطقه ففي ابريل
نيسان من العام الحالي ذكر مسؤولون
امريكيون لوكاله الصحافه الفرنسيه ان
الولايات المتحده يعد مساعده طويله الامد
بساحل العاج وبنين وتوجو مع تزايد المخاوف
من ان تتمدد الجماعات المسلحه في منطقه
الساحل الى الساحل الغربي
ينضم الينا الان من واشنطن
الباحث في مركز
مدير بالاحرى مدير البحوث في مركز افريقيا
للدراسات الاستراتيجيه اهلا وسهلا بك
لماذا هذه المنطقه الان تحولت الى بؤره
تجاذب جيوستراتيجي بين الغرب
بالاساس وروسيا من جهه اخرى
سالنا منطقه الساحل هي مفترق طرق طبعا بين
شمال افريقيا
شبه الصحراء
وايضا هي ايضا
منطقه التي
شهدت تقدما كبيرا في التوجه نحو
الديمقراطيه وقد شاهدنا خلال السنوات
العشره الماضيه مالي وبوركينا فاسو وغينيا
والنيجر كلها اتخذت خطوات مهمه وكبيره
للتحول نحو الديمقراطيه
والان واذا
هو اذ ان هذه المنطقه اصبحت ديمقراطيه
شاهدنا بعض التراجعات
قام بها
الاطراف العسكريه في هذه الدول التي لديهم
تاريخ الحكم العسكري
وبالتالي هناك في الحقيقه الان
مواجهه مواجهه بين الاطراف العسكريه
والاطراف الديمقراطيه من اجل مصير هذه
المنطقه ومستقبلها وان هذه الجهود التي
يبذلها الطرف العسكري للسيطره على السلطه
هي التي
تعرض المنطقه لنفوذ الخارجي خاصه النفوذ
الروسي للحصول على المزيد من السيطره
روسيا لم تستثمر كثيرا في اي من هذه الدول
ولكنها تامل الان
تحصل على نفوذ بفضل هؤلاء العسكر والتخلص
من النفوذ على الاقل الفرنسي في المنطقه
النفود الفرنسي تقريبا النيجر هو اخر موضع
قدم للقوات الفرنسيه هل معنى ذلك ان لا
احد قادر على تعويض فرنسا من القوه
الغربيه هناك
ان هناك
اي دوله بمفردها
يمكن ان تقدم شموليه شموليه الترابط
والاتصال الذي حققته فرنسا في منطقه
الساحل ولكن رغم ذلك
فان الاتحاد الاوروبي ككل
استثمر الكثير والكثير في هذه منطقه
الساحل والساحل كما قلنا مفترق طرق
يمتد من الافرقه الى اوروبا
وبالتالي من حيث الاستثمارات والتجاره
ومساعدات التنمويه
فان الاتحاد الاوروبي ساهم بكمياته بشكل
كبير جدا في هذه المنطقه
واجمل نعلم بان هذه المنطقه افقر مناطق
العالم كما اهل النقطه الرئيسيه
للمهاجرين الاقتصاديين لاسباب الماليه
الذين يتطلعون الحصول على فرص عمل
بالتوجه الى اطراف اخرى من شمال افريقيا
وبعضهم يعبرون المتوسط الى اوروبا
شكرا جزيلا
معذره على المقاطعه شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
في سياق الحصاد ناقشنا الوضع الميداني
والسياسي والمواقف الخارجيه ولكن ماذا عن
الانسان تقريراته مشتركه لوكاله الامم
المتحده ومنظمات غير حكوميه وجماعات اخرى
تقول ان عدد الذين يعانون انعدام الامن
الغذائي زاد بشكل حاد في السودان بوتيره
اسرع من المتوقع الى اكثر من 20 مليون شخص
اي ما يعادل
42% من السكان وكشفت تصنيف ان عدد الذين
يواجهون الجوع الشديد ويحتاجون الى دعم
عاجل ازداد باكثر من ثمانيه ملايين ونصف
المليون شخص مقارنه بالفتره نفسها من
العام الماضي هي ارقام وحقائق تذكرنا
بتكلفه الصراعات والثمن الباهظ الذي يدفعه
دوما المدني لا سيما الفئات الاكثر ضعفا
نامل ان يعم السلام لعمه ارجاء العالم
وحلم وامل علينا التمسك به رغم الصعوبات
والتعقيدات والمناغصات دمتم بخير والى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]